please be with you welcome to the Dean
show come on take a second before we
start the show and subscribe right now
if you have it my next guest spent 10
years pursuing the Hollywood dream he
was striving to be like Denzel
Washington consumed that's all he was
consumed with was being a start till
finally getting a break getting a role
and then putting a break to it all you
want to know why we can get the ins and
outs of the Hollywood lifestyle for
those who maybe got their bags packed
and they're ready to go hold up watch
this week's show and then make your
decision at the end we'll be right back
with this exciting episode here the Dean
shell don't know anywhere
this is the this is the beam you know
this is the days of the engine you know
this is the things you only compete with
you well alaikum salam' enough not LA
but Noah yes sir named after one of the
greatest messengers that ever walked the
earth yes sir yes sir how did you why'd
you come up with this name your parents
came up with it yeah yeah yeah my dad he
um he wasn't born Muslim and so his mom
named him Nora because she was from
Mississippi and she had a dick accident
but she was trying to say Noah and so he
changed his name to to Noah and he start
practicing Islam and it just just worked
out like that so 10 10 years you were in
the Hollywood scene exactly exactly and
the Hollywood pursuing the dream of
acting I was I started out in Grand
Rapids Michigan I was in Community
College and I took an intro to theater
class and it was everything that had to
do with theater from lighting to
blocking and stuff and so they used to
have us to people stand on on the set
and they would have them do a little
scene so other people can like practice
lighting and stuff like that and when we
would improv the different scenes I
guess I caught the acting bug is what
they called it you know and from there I
went to a Howard University and I
studied film and then I came to
Hollywood and I started the grind of
trying to be an actor you know going
from one agency to the next with my
headshot passing it out you know trying
to get an agent you know and
I ended up booking an agent and they
started sending me out to commercial
auditions all kind of auditions and
that's when I booked a role on the
shield and I booked a Domino's
commercial a couple other commercials
and a pilot with a comedian famous
comedian um Andy Andy Dick it was from
from MTV so who are some of your
favorite actors that you were aspiring
to be like um Denzel Washington
definitely I used to watch a lot of his
movies Chris Tucker you know with his
comedy and how how much of a livewire he
was and I would look at them and study
tapes and when I was in acting classes
and things of that nature I would do
scenes out of their movies and stuff
like that so I definitely those two
right there we're definitely my the ones
who I aspired to be like tell us some of
the in some of the on-the-ground action
that happens down in Hollywood because
people see the big Hollywood sign right
and people like they save up money yeah
maybe they leave school leave their
family and run away yeah run away to get
to Hollywood they land
touchdown they're like we made it this
is our paradise exactly exactly I
diseased man you know what it's the
thing about it is so very few people
reach that upper level where they're
actually on TV and working on a regular
basis many of the people who are in
Hollywood are just aspiring you know
it's thousands and thousands of people
who are aspiring to be to be famous and
things of that nature and that right
there is ugly because because just did
the competition there's no rules you
know I mean you would show up to
auditions and see somebody who you were
good friends with and they they don't
even speak to you you know you would
have agents who have hundreds
representing hundreds and hundreds of
actors and they're just taking on
clients in order to maybe one
of them we'll make it big you know not
necessarily I'm invested in each one of
these people's careers
I'm just looking for wanting to make it
big so I can make some money or how are
you onset whether you're doing extra
work or anything like that the the
fitnah that goes on with the with the
with the sisters who who may think that
you know getting to know you a little
little better will boost their career
you know so it's a lot of things
distracting you from the actual movie
making which you do so so little of you
know the actual time on set
and making movies is very is very small
in the in the in the Hollywood industry
you spend most of the time trying to to
make it big taking acting classes which
which which drain your pocket taking
headshots which which drain your pocket
and all of these things you you you look
at all of these avenues and it's hard to
decipher the real from the fake you know
you go to parties and you meet people
and you question your own self like like
do I just want to get to know this
person so I can succeed more or is this
person getting to know me so so they can
succeed more you know so like they say
Hollywood is an is an illusion it's
definitely an illusion because you know
you don't know exactly what's real and
what's not real I can imagine for our
sisters out there you know just women in
general in the entity the kind of traps
that can fall in people taking advantage
of them because they want to like
achieve this position this role so
certain agents or even producers just
taking women really you know there's a
new documentary that is all about the
dark side of Hollywood and how some
power players allegedly use their
positions to prey on young aspiring
actors but Evan may not be the only one
the manager also allegedly abused the
late Corey Haim and Corey Feldman
Feldman told us it didn't in there when
I look back at a picture of when I was
15 years old and I was surrounded by
five men and every
one of those men in that photograph is a
pedophile it's a pretty big problem
think about it they're on each other
definitely yeah yeah you would think
that it's a lot of diabolical men just
preying on these women big-time but in
general you you might go to set in it
maybe two or three when the praying are
you hmm you know and it's you know it's
in general it's more women and men just
in general yeah and so women
oh I'm not all of the women but some of
the women they go with it with the
intention that they're going to you know
do things like that so you as a man you
you are preyed on also you you you
obviously a lot of people end up selling
their soul down yeah even men probably
men trying to get other men to do
certain things this is everyday business
and he made me feel like I have to do
that in order to get any job yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I've been great assume
that stuff personally but I've heard
stories about that you know and it's all
for people who just who just want to be
famous yeah who want to do something
with themselves and who are confused
that's exactly what what success is you
know yeah you realize at that time you
weren't really practicing anything not
like I should definitely definitely yeah
and and we find this I mean we want to
kind of give people the inside look
what's going on why is Dave Chappelle
going Africa why is Mariah Carey make
100 million dollar deal and take clothes
off on TRL it is a wig person cannot get
to sit here and talk to you ain't a week
people talking to you so what is
happening in Hollywood
nobody knows before maybe somebody you
know they forget about their purpose in
life their purpose they make this their
purpose you met you said only a small
very small percentage but actually even
make it and even when you do make it at
the end it's a whole nother world of
driving exactly whole nother world of
drama you know at the Screen Actors
Guild which is the the guild that if you
want to work in the industry you have to
join its
only about 2% of those people who are
part of that that guilt that actually
work so 98% of the people are either
worked actors you know just struggling
to to make it somewhere you know and
like you say the perp the person with
purpose can can definitely lose their
the the purpose pursuing something like
that you know it's almost like somebody
who is a who's trained not to eat in the
right way if a person is not trained to
eat in the right way then whenever
they're hungry they'll just just grab
anything they'll just try to eat
anything whether it be fattening or
anything like that it's the same thing
about people who want want success
they're just trying to get it in the
wrong way yeah we're going to talk about
what real successes definitely want to
get more of your journey how you
actually found out well how you actually
started really engrossing yourself to
living the full purpose of life to reach
your full potential and how you're doing
something actually something really
beneficial now I'm they do that here on
the Dean show we'll be right back with
noah don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the DCO follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
back here addy show with special guest
Noah was in Hollywood yes sir on the
strip Hollywood Boulevard you're trying
to get one of those stars definitely
yeah yeah you got a crazy thing about
that is when you walk down the strip of
Hollywood and you see those stars on the
ground for me it probably was about 70
to 80% of those people I didn't even
know who they were I didn't even know
who they were you know these are people
who reach the top of knowledge you know
when you're the top of Hollywood you
that you're the top of the whole whole
world you know and you have these people
who are just just will do anything to
get to that point and you just go a
couple of years outside of the realm and
people don't even don't even know who
you are you know and it's
lot of controversy going on right now
with the with the you know getting
Oscars and things of that nature and for
me it goes down to people putting hope
in the wrong things you know because the
the thing about pursuit pursuing success
it was putting us by Allah you know to
pursue success and the pursuit of
success is so fiery and it's so hot
within the soul you know and if you're
pursuing it in the wrong way you will
pursue that just like you you should be
pursuing it for Allah but you're
pursuing it for something else you know
because when I was in Hollywood and our
really was was gunning and trying to be
the top a-list actor I used to think
about it all the time every day when I
when I woke up in the morning I would
think about man how am I gonna do it I
need to go to this acting class I need
to do this I need to do that whenever I
ate I'm like okay I need to stop eating
you know so much because I need to save
my money so I can take some headshots
you go on some kind of a fast definitely
yeah yeah yes starving actors stars and
and and just to pay the ring just to
take these acting classes just did till
they got a bunch of rituals that you're
actually going through it becomes a your
whole life it's like you're consumed
using your bigness own with it yeah
totally consumed with it and that's
interesting people are reaching for the
stars but now they're actually on the
lowest part under people's feet is that
you go look at these stars that aren't
on the strip people are walking walking
on them you know they that's like
Muhammad Ali told them to put my star on
the wall because you know that these are
tough exactly yeah yeah so cuz you can't
you can't walk on the name Muhammad
that's amazing
yeah so his star is actually on the wall
yeah you know I'm saying don't put my
star on the floor exactly here everyone
just give me a starting walk exactly no
no it was like if you don't give me one
it can't it can't be walked on now tell
us more I mean obviously before we get
to real purpose what you're living now
and you got to see probably a lot of
things a lot of people selling
themselves yeah their souls you know
people who actually make it many people
think okay I made it to be a star that's
happiness that's purpose in life how far
away can this be from the truth it's as
far as you can as you can imagine you
know because people who are who are
pursuing that are actually pursuing
something that's that's legit you know
because the pursuit of success is like I
said it within us all so the pursuit of
something that validates you that makes
it seem like you accomplished something
is natural but we need to do that in the
way of Allah because if we don't once we
reach it you know it's not going to do
what what we thought it would do you
know Rosie O'Donnell she had one that
she had a powerful quote and she said
that Fame let her down because she felt
like when she reached Fame that it will
solve all of her problems but it didn't
you know and so I think that people who
are who are pursuing that they are
running themselves ragged to that to
that point you know and it says in the
Quran in surah al-kahf verse 103 and 104
Allah says he says I'll tell you who are
the greatest of losers and he says those
are the ones who whose pursuits are all
within the worldly life and they don't
they don't consider they don't think
about the higher purpose which is which
is uh which is a lot you know and that
hit me because I was like man people go
through a lot to reach success like you
say um not eating you know waking up at
3 and 4 o'clock in the morning
to shoot basketballs if you're trying to
be in the NBA but in Hollywood
sacrificing yourself you know going to
these acting classes and things of that
nature to think that at the end of your
life you can have five or six Oscars
everybody in this world could know your
name everybody could be wearing a you
your clothing line or something like
that and at the end of the day
everything to be lost yeah like that
means that the check station before you
cross over into the next line you need a
visa that visa stamped by the Creator
yes belief in him doing those righteous
good keys but those Oscars listen if you
do win tonight remember that no one
cares about that award as much as you do
okay I've got three I've got three
golden roads myself so I can set ones a
doorstop when I use to hit burglars with
and when I keep by the bed desk top and
get you in
no that's don't dare gets to me it
doesn't mean anything tell us how do you
how do you how do you feel and how would
you advise people who even many Muslims
they fall in this trap
they're pursuing that dream maybe
they're out there making some YouTube
video here doing some of the most
ridiculous silly and other things that
compromise their Deen and they end up
maybe being YouTube sensations and they
want to be stars reaching for the stars
but again you see the most ridiculous
things that are being done in the name
of this stardom exactly exactly and now
renting YouTube pay to a while you know
and I had that that similar mentality
you know because you don't want
everything to fall into just views and
hits and things of this nature you know
because that that validates you also man
if I got a million views that means
everybody likes me you know you have to
focus on who are you doing it for if
you're doing it for people to approve
what you're doing you're doing it for
the wrong reasons do everything strictly
for the purpose of gaining the pleasure
of Allah if you have that in your scope
you always going to be on there on the
right direction you know so people who
put it out there you know do pranks and
things of that nature in order just to
build themselves up here I'm not gonna
speak for everybody but you'll find
those people who don't consider the next
life at all and you know for a Muslim
for us not to look at the afterlife
that's one of the worst things that you
can do you know that's one of the
easiest ways to lose yourself we're
going to take a break I'll be right back
with more you want to know what finally
did it for you that then you know
started living purpose and some of the
work that you're doing now here in a
Deen show or no don't go anywhere please
subscribe to the D show follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here in the D show with Noah alright so
you got a roll you got a few rolls yeah
you're in the shield as a big that's a
series actually yeah yeah really one on
Vaughn yeah you got a roll in there you
did some other commercial you starting
slowly you know to climb the ladder what
happens you end up I'm in another ladder
exactly exactly
well I just you know um from there I
reached a lot of success there and or
some just a little bit just a little
taste that's all you really need and
start doing YouTube for a while you know
and built up of following me on youtube
you know got millions of views on my
videos and then I started to take a life
of the Prophet class that was one of the
first things that that that triggered it
for me that I was going in the wrong
direction you know and from the life of
the product of the Prophet class I took
a purification of the heart class and
that class right there it basically it
it pinpoints all of the diseases of the
heart you know and just like a
basketball player or a football player
depending on what sports you play
depending on what type of injury you're
you're prone to so depending on what we
do in life is
is depending on what we do in life is
what you're more likely to get a disease
of the heart in so since taking that
class
I looked at myself and said I may have
the disease of the heart for the want
for fame you know and if you want for
fame and status on this world then you
kind of spoil your blessings you know
and so that right there made me
introspectively looked at everything
that I had ever done on screen on camera
anything like that and man it hit me
like a ton of bricks
you know I said man if I can get a
million hits on this video or if I can
do TV and a million people were looking
at me
why can I stand up and say Leila hilar
law on camera and the familiar people
look at me doing that then it would be
good for the people here and it would be
good for my afterlife I can't I can't do
anything on film from this point on that
will not help me here and in the
afterlife and I'm dead that made me
change everything that made me change my
production company from Adventures of
Noah sy productions to sort of a la
productions even in my production
company I said if you know if you just
reading the name of my production
company I wanted to give Dawa everything
that I do on screen I wanted to give
Dawa everything is for the grace and
mercy of Allah you know now someone says
look you know with all the hype about
Muslims not your Muslims out there so
here these Muslims sort of Allah yeah
what would you say well the thing about
it is my last name is a cipher lock in
in unite that means sort of a lot so my
last name means that exactly so it's
just it's just it's just uh it's just my
last name but now so much was even in
his last name exactly's guys are violet
what a thing about it is have you ever
had been now definitely
yeah yeah yeah well the first thing
about it let's let's let's dissect what
a sword is a sword was made by Allah and
it was made so powerful that you can go
to war with it but it's so delicate that
you can slice a piece you can spread
butter on a piece of bread with it so
the actual mechanism which is a sword is
a beautiful creation within itself it's
nothing wrong with that and not only
that if you put anything before Allah
that's a servant of Allah
so don't matter if it's a sword if it's
a book if it's anything it's a servant
you know so a sword of Allah is still a
servant of Allah because whatever it's
used for is used for something that
Allah has decreed you know so sort of a
lot of productions is servant of a lot
of production slave of Allah productions
it is because anything you put in before
Allah is is serving a lot now we noticed
I noticed that knowledge was was a key
component and to the transformation yep
this was something that really now that
you took this class he started to grow
in knowledge and and the transformation
was a difficult was it something that
you you really had to struggle against
your desires now to leave off because
now you're gaining some popularity yeah
yeah they're probably not transferable
and please ago to the Creator you got to
leave it off how was that struggle oh
the struggle is real because the stuff
that was left on me was so many remnants
of the dunya you know and so many of
your your goals and aspirations are just
attached to that and you just have to
just mentally just leave it alone you
know you you think to yourself man if I
just had a fast car if I just had a big
house if I just had you know a beautiful
model life you know my life would be be
complete and just the constant reminders
from the dunya in TV and so that's why
you gotta you have to change everything
you know you can't I'm switching my life
around but I still watch these shows I'm
switching my life around but I don't you
know read Quran or anything no you have
to just totally abandon every
you know in in in fill your life with
the things that are conducive to the way
you want to live if you do that then the
transition would be easier of getting
out of the dunya because you will still
have things on you from the dunya no
stains still remind you of that so I
think just as long as you're you're
committed to the total transformation it
would be easier but it's definitely not
an easy process you started making
videos on the importance of fudger was
making about back by the yeah fasting we
got like one minute left tell us about
what went into the thought process that
went into these um just a just given
Dawa just I'm doing doing videos that
may help Muslims will help anybody you
know so um praying Phaedra the Battle of
Roger man maybe I can make a movie that
a debtor that help people get up in the
morning you know the dangers of
backbiting a sin that could you know eat
away from our deeds on the owner on the
day of judgment you know things that can
actually people can watch in and kind of
wake up you know and the the feature
film that I have that I'm in production
with the search for Sakina the same
thing you know everybody is on the
search for Sakina Sakina means peace and
tranquility yeah you know so um just
putting it out there you know in every
way shape or form
worship Allah remember Allah you know
this is this is what we're supposed to
be doing like last uh few seconds that
we have someone out there got the tune
in and they're also aspiring I got the
bags packed they're about to leave the
Hollywood hey what advice would you give
um don't forget about a lot don't forget
about a life you go into Hollywood and
you and you're and you're pursuing a
career in Hollywood do not forget about
a lot because if you forget about a lot
it don't matter how much money you make
you can have 813 Oscars it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter if you forget
about a lot but if you remember a lot
everything you do that's going to change
that's gonna change everything you do
the decisions you make everything so
never
to get about a lot never forget the one
who created you to hear them as an herb
thank you so much thank you being with
us no thank you thank you for having
really bless you thank you for being
with us and I'm like welcome awakens
alright there was no I here on addy show
for those people who had had their bags
packed and they were right out the door
almost hopefully you're unpacking right
now you have a change of heart
connecting that heart you know there's
things that stopped the human being from
doing what's intrinsically embedded in
all of us it's a part of human nature to
believe in the Almighty Creator it's
it's they've done Studies on this this
is something that's verified you know
it's acquired to disbelieve in God but
the things that hinder us are those
desires so you might have a desire for
fame desire for fornication for drugs
alcohol desires you got to put a check
on that if you're about to get a job
that's going to pay you and an
exorbitant of money with so many
benefits but there's certain
requirements that need to be fulfilled
are you going to forsake that job for
your desires or know you'll be
intelligent enough to leave off the
things that aren't good for you and
fulfill those requirements so you can
get those that position and get that
payday right yeah makes sense but
everything that Allah the creator of
heavens and earth told us to stay away
from are things that are not good for us
things that are harmful for us and now
is the time that we need to make a
change and you weren't created to win
Emmys and Oscars and to be a Hollywood
superstar that's not the things that you
should be consuming your mind with and
take it from not me take it from for
instance Jim Carrey you know what he
said it's interesting I think that
everyone should get rich and famous and
do everything that they ever dreamed of
so at the end they can they can see that
that's not the answer telling you that
right now take it from Jim I mean this
is a a star actor at the top of the
class that class rose to fame
but you see that that does not fill the
void in the heart and many of these if
not the overwhelming majority of
Hollywood actors are on antidepressants
they're on drugs alcohol very arrogant
very miserable people living miserable
shallow lives and you have a chance
either to go in that direction and at
the end maybe you might make it but then
you make it like Jim Carrey said you
make it to the top and you realize hey
what's up here I'm even lonelier than
when I was at the bottom or you can
focus your efforts on to something that
you were created for to do something not
to chase this world but to help change
the world for the better that's what the
Creator had made you for to worship Him
alone and to play your role to the best
of its ability doing the things that
Allah the Almighty had told you to do
and we have that all laid out in this
beautiful way of life get to know it and
when he did you see when Noah he took
that class and now had a different
perspective about life knowledge if you
just bump in 50 cents all day and night
don't worry about Katy Perry or whoever
else is out there nowadays was hitting
the charts
who's got maybe like almost a billion
hits on the youtubes I mean they're
going to have a big following because
shakedown is taking a lot of people but
except them for those few those small
few that are loyal and committed to
pleasing their creator doing the good
that he's told us to do and that's how
you reach it charge your heart that's
how you get that peace that's how you
get that happiness that fulfillment that
contentment that money can't buy and
you're going to get it with I don't care
how many Grammys are Emmys you win make
a change right now for the better leave
off all those things just the same way
you'd leave them off if it was for
monetary gain for benefits of this world
but the best is when you can have this
world in your hand and but then you
strive and struggle for the best in the
hereafter by being good doing good
living a righteous wholesome life we'll
see you next time right now stop if you
have it subscribe right now do it and
we'll see you next time here Today Show
get it go good
or see a piece please subscribe to the
DVR follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below